all right snow white yes
snow white welcome back thank you it's
been a while since we've seen you what
uh
what's been going on since since i saw
you last last time i saw you you were
pregnant
right um ever since then um i miscarried
oh you missed carrie yes um
that was kind of rough for me you know
because yeah
i mean a baby is is life you know but
um yeah and uh
i'm still out there doing what i was
doing before
right and your drug is still still on
crack
and um it just seems to be getting
the same same even though i try you know
but crack is um i mean
every addiction is difficult but crack
seems to really be a difficult one
yeah for a lot of people and it's very
expensive
is it the most expensive drug um
i think maybe yeah it depends on how
much you use it yeah
yeah yeah yeah between heroin and and
that
yeah crack is very expensive like they
say that's a rich man's drug or
something like that
right but um yeah it's uh
starting to get a little bit more
difficult out here because it's colder
you know
yeah it's cold in the winter even though
it's california
the nights are terrible yeah and even
you've been living this
this life for how long um probably about
uh
almost going on a year and a half now
yeah do you feel like you're changing
yeah definitely how how so um
you'll do things that you wouldn't do
before
or you know like um and um
um just your uh your behaviors and
and and stuff like that you know
definitely change
and but but like specifically in what
what like oh like um
okay for instance like uh before like i
wouldn't
do anything for less than say uh a
certain amount of money you know what i
mean and now uh
because i have the addiction or whatever
and i just want to go in and get high
like i'll just say okay go ahead you
know whenever
did you get asked to do things that
maybe you would that you wouldn't
normally do
yeah or that you don't like you or
should i say that you don't like doing
you know you would do you know and um
yeah so it gets and then the
it's it's almost you your your story is
as a child you had some yeah i had a
rough growing up
yeah it's almost like that creates this
shame it brings it brings back a whole
bunch of
memories from from childhood and stuff
like that you know but as i hear these
stories it seems like that kind of
event in your childhood creates the
shame and the drugs kind of numb the
pain of the shame
right and then the behavior creates more
shame and it's a cycle
it's a psycho it's a snowball it's a
snowball yeah definitely and then um
you know we all say uh
you know what numbs and everything like
that but eventually reality does come
back you know so it only just numbs for
just the moment yeah and the longer
you're out here the more your life
and it's just getting snowballing bigger
and bigger
your life unravels further and further
right right
and you just feel like that um you're
just like okay well
uh it's already gotten this far you know
how am i gonna fix it or
and then it gets to the point to where
it's like oh forget it like
and you just keep doing the same thing
over and over and over again do you have
other kids
yeah i have i have um three kids all
together
one is adopted one is with her father
and one is with her grandmother
yeah and then
tell me how how like karma plays out in
your life i mean
because living living this kind of life
it probably this is not an ideal life
for anyone never
ever ever and it's definitely not fun
it's definitely not
easy and um whoever says that um that
they've had fun
or anything like that you know what i
mean uh no no
no that's not what it is but um
it's just it's just supporting your
addiction yes supporting my addiction
definitely yeah and um
uh as far as um what did you ask i was
asking about karma
i mean do you feel karma karma let me
tell you about karma
um okay uh yes definitely karma is real
and um regrets you know because um
my children are my life believe it or
not you know what i mean
but it's pretty crazy because not even
my children
will bring me back and that's um very
selfish
very selfish because the children suffer
also of course yeah
believe it or not they suffer the most
you know and um they didn't ask
for none of that they didn't ask for
none of that
you know but um it's just the power of
addiction
power of addiction i think that's what i
mean
you'll see comments on this video and a
lot of others that people saying oh just
just quit go to rehab and negatively
yeah and everybody says oh um uh just
one time or
i have control or i don't do the drug or
the drug don't do me the
the i do the drug and that's all
[ __ ]
because if i was to walk here walk you
over to a rehab right now
you walk in the door what would happen
uh if i even walk into the door
i'll be gone within yeah right yeah i've
heard this a thousand times you know
because it will not happen unless you
want it to happen
it doesn't matter if jail and cops and
the judge tells you and do
you know what i mean until you are ready
your family your friends your kids your
everybody can want it for children
if your children is not enough okay and
i'm a mother
i mean if your children is not enough
then what is it you know so addiction is
very very very very powerful
what do you think most people that don't
do drugs
don't understand about an addict's
situation no i don't think that um by
going to school
and doing all that you know what i mean
because you seem very intelligent yeah
you have to actually go through it to
completely
understand you know what i mean what it
is
you know and um it's definitely
when they say it's a monkey on your back
you know what i mean because let me tell
you what
um crack goes first
for anything for me for anything
and it's not about common sense or
reason
or intelligence no that's not
i know yeah that doesn't matter no
because you you seem very sensible yeah
that's that monkey tapping
on the back like hey look check it out
this is what you're gonna go do
and you're going to go do it and you're
not strong enough to stop it
and there are moments probably in your
day where you say no i'm going to stop
but then within three hours later oh
yeah yeah
you're doing it i can be in a totally
really bad situation
very dangerous situation you know what i
mean and for that moment while i'm going
through my little scared and i'm so
upset or whatever whatever like never
again never again
trust and believe within 24 less than 24
hours i'm doing the same thing over
again
have you lost your relationship with
your family and kids
i'm sure it suffered because of this oh
yes definitely um
yeah i'm on my way to losing my daughter
i
my parental rights have been taken she's
just an adoption process right now
my father will not speak to me at all
mothers you know how mothers are you
know she
uh i'm always i'm always
welcome home but definitely not doing
the same thing
you know but it's not only about that
it's just um
it's just the letdowns you know what i
mean and the and the
and the you know it's just you you put
them through it also
you know because um a lot of people have
called me and been like what are you
doing your mother your mother's gonna
die of stress
lady you know what i mean like your
mother really loves you like
you need to go home like what are you
doing out here there's nothing out here
for you
and people just don't understand people
don't understand correct
heroin yeah because if you if you could
you would
simple as that yeah you're sensible it's
not fun out here it's not easy out here
you know what i mean i do not like what
i do at all
you know living in a tent is not
comfortable
it's not uh this is not a life
no you have no love life right no you
have no love isn't that there
in these streets there's nothing called
love out here
and my only love right now i'll tell you
is crack cocaine
that's something that's just complete
honesty you know
do you have hope of climbing out of this
situation
yeah i hope so i want uh
i think i want to but what do you think
might actually
turn make you turn the corner on i'm
going there
i don't know i hope that one day i
finally wake up and say
this is enough of this because i mean
what else is gonna work
i don't want this no more you know
i mean i hope so i really do
but is is picking up the crack pipe your
biggest regret
in life um
yeah one of them yes yeah
definitely so
you must in moments where you're by
yourself just sit there and
look back at your life and go that's
part of karma that's definitely part of
karma right there
because that don't stop that will not
stop that's always that's good so
there's
a lot of guilt oh yeah guilt shame
you carry that with you everywhere yeah
yeah i think shane's a huge part of all
of this
yeah yeah people don't understand the
power of shame
yeah i don't like mirrors
i don't like mirrors yeah
yeah i don't like um i don't like a lot
of time
you know i'm constantly uh trying to be
busy to stay
to not have that that
i'm not having to face that part you
know so you don't really have good days
where
where you're just happy to be alive um
not not when you're separated from your
kids yeah no
no even the very best day you're still
what's the best day though
the biggest hole in your life is there
yeah yeah just to
the best day with just to to be able to
um
be sober and be able to
to hug my children just one more time
you know just one more time if that's
all i could get
yeah because that's that's the most
difficult part right there
is my children because i adore them i
adore them they are
i mean that's my life right there you
know
and there's nobody who loves me more
than them too
you still talk to them no not anymore we
don't yeah
that's not why thank you for giving us
this little thank you window into
the reality of this life yeah thank you
because it's not just
bad decisions you've made yeah maybe the
one bad decision was picking up that
pipe
right correct but other than that it
becomes out of your control yeah all
right
thank you very much thank you